crisis and political unrest in just a
few short week they appear to have put a
serious damper on the world economic
mood what kind of an affect our flash
points like these having on world
economic activity that's what are we
talking about with Devin Schneider from
Deutsche Bank research mr. Schneider how
has the nibix your business economic
parameter developed in face of all these
crisis situations if we look at the
dbags for the global economy as a whole
actually those crises are not really
showing up it's still unchanged at plus
point eight like in the previous month
however if we look at the contributions
then we can see a clear divergence
evolving in particular the u.s. is
really steaming ahead very good numbers
pointing to a continued stronger than
second half of the year whereas in
Europe and I think here one of the
crisis is having an impact already
namely the Ukraine crisis especially
particularly on Germany we can see that
business conditions have deteriorated
quite considerably China is softening
somewhat but still doing a clay and
Japan which is in a kind of special
situation given the introduction of the
sales text in the second quarter is more
or less moving sideways how serious
impact can flash points like these have
in the long term I mean it obviously
depends how these crisis evolve and I
think the most obvious one is the
Ukraine crisis a further escalation of
sanctions would certainly not help we
might see further retaliations from
Russia and so this will probably and not
only have very short-term effects on
exports which are very clearly visible
in German exports are down by more than
fifteen percent towards Russia but it
should also weigh on investment spending
and maybe if we look at consumer
confidence data and looked into the
details we can see also that the
expectations of consumers regard a
business cycle outlook have dropped
dramatically so they could even have an
impact there in the very long term it
obviously depends on what's going to
happen with the peace dividend weather
and
we have just the NATO summit whether the
Western countries will come to the
conclusion that they have in the
medium-term to ratchet up their defense
expenditures hmm at the moment everyone
seems to be counting on strong data from
the US but is this enough of a buffer to
reverse worst consequences for the world
economy I mean it certainly helps the
u.s. is still the biggest economy in the
world it has a strong demand effect on
as especially the smaller Asian
economies but also in Mexico and Canada
but I mean the scenario everyone hoped
for was strong growth coming from the US
and China and this basically pushing
global trade in higher territory this is
not materializing global trade is still
basically bumping along at the growth
rates of round two half three percent
and this is really one of the reasons
why the situation in Europe but also in
Japan is not improving as expected yes
well Europe is very threatening to fall
into recession is this homemade problem
or is this a due to their geopolitical
crisis city where various aspects I
think it's very difficult to distinct
the various aspects I mean obviously
Russia is an important factor especially
in Germany but we will see that some of
the sanctions might also have an impact
on some of the other countries and
especially given that Germany is a very
important market for other European
countries it might have indirect effects
on the other crisis so far the the
problems in the Middle East haven't
really impacted the oil price which
would be the transmission into into
Europe but but I think again it's
external but it's also internal that
there is some disappointment of regards
to reforms in various countries and on
the contrary I mean the political
situation in some of the countries has
become more difficult and they hope that
there will be a kind of a stronger paste
towards reforms have diminished thank
you very much much later this month we
will be talking about unease in Europe
and post
that Europe could turn away from
austerity programs from on that go head
for DWT e / english / made in germany